how are we feeling guys dead due to
overexposure to excitement me too fam me
too I personally cannot stop coming up
with conclusions and theories about all
the new footage we were shown in
yesterday's brand new tears of the
Kingdom trailer and it it just feels so
good to actually know the name now tears
of the Kingdom big stuff coming by the
way you're gonna want to be subscribed
for it but anyway one comment that I
keep seeing in my previous videos though
has surfaced enough times for me to make
this quick video about it so let's get
into it lots of fans who saw the trailer
have come to the conclusion that this
levitating character on the mural is
Ganondorf or at least the corpse we're
all assuming Ganondorf that was shown in
the first and second trailers at first
glance I can understand where people are
coming from Ganondorf is strangely
wearing some sort of robe or dress and
has a beautiful head of long flowing
hair seriously his genetics are not
lacking he also has yet another version
of his iconic forehead Jewel on his
forehead and is in a position that looks
like he's leaning backwards leading to
his upper body almost being parallel
with the ground if you compare this with
the levitating character on the mural
the similarities are obvious the pose is
strikingly similar to ganondorf's
backward leaning stance the forehead
Sports what could be that Jewel thing
and the character is also dressed in a
robe or dress there also appears to be
malice beneath the character which as we
know is closely associated with and
comes from Ganondorf however I
personally do not believe this is meant
to symbolize Ganondorf for three main
reasons first the malice that is shown
underneath the character is just that
underneath it not coming from it or
originating from the character like we
see happening with the Ganondorf corpse
if you think about it this actually
implies that the character is separate
from malice not a part of it second the
character features pointed ears while
ganondorf's corpse specifically does not
for those who are curious as to why this
is It's because the old Garuda from the
days of Ocarina of Time had regularly
rounded ears as opposed to the Hylian
rays and slowly due to cross reading
developed pointed ears of their own but
anyway moving on third this character is
the exact same character as the one
who's shown right after this cupping
hands with the strange deity individual
at first glance you might think not but
the more you look at them the more you
can see that they're literally the same
the hair is patterned exactly the same
falling over the air they have the same
pointed ears the dress is shown to be
worn below the shoulders and the dress
patterns match up just from different
viewing angles the forehead symbol
matches the eyes match even the way the
arms are drawn match in my opinion this
character shown twice on the mural has
to be Zelda since the appearance has a
striking resemblance to Zelda in her
goddess dress complete with the flowing
long hair and shoulderless dress with a
belt I personally feel like this portion
here may actually be a prophecy of Zelda
falling into malice which we kind of
sort of may have actually seen happen in
the previous trailer however it could
also mean something completely different
I could be way off but I for sure do not
think this character is Ganondorf and I
for sure think it's Zelda instead now
the next natural question is who is the
strange seven-tier deity character and
why is she Cup in hands with Zelda
thought that was Link's job but you'll
just have to stay tuned for that theory
coming real soon in the meantime though
thank you guys so much for watching this
shorter theory of mine and I'm curious
to know what you guys think be sure to
let me know exactly that in the comments
below like the video If you enjoyed it
and subscribe if you haven't already
because come on there's some good stuff
coming you know there is anyway that's
all I've got so be sure to follow me on
my socials below this is Bandit signing
out peace
[Music]
foreign
[Music]